let's talk about what's going on with
Brett Cavanaugh the Senate Judiciary
Committee held hearings about Donald
Trump's Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh last week they're scheduled to
vote on September 20th and what has
transpired in these hearings is nothing
short of absolutely stunning now I could
spend a bunch of time talking about this
amazing exchange that took place between
senator Kamala Harris and Kavanagh
during which Cavanaugh sort of played
dom and played semantics games around
whether or not he had spoken to people
in the justice system about the robert
muller trump russia investigation but
that was dealt with last week by our
guest hosts adequately so I'm gonna move
on from that what I want to talk to you
about today is about straight-up perjury
right lying under oath during
confirmation hearings remember that
Brett Kavanagh has had confirmation
hearings before he has had a
confirmation hearings in at least in
2004 and 2006 for lower Court judgeships
and like last week he was similarly
under oath during these prior
confirmation hearings and we now have a
treasure trove of documents that have
been released relating to Brett
Kavanaugh and there is just too much
that directly contradicts things he said
during these prior confirmation hearings
over the years to say that they were
anything other than lies now of course a
lie is not necessarily perjury perjury
is very difficult to prosecute and prove
but we'll talk about that a little bit I
also want to make clear this the the
details not the specifics but the
details of each of the lies aren't so
important I'm gonna give you the
overview of each of the lies because
really what I want to talk about is the
bigger picture so here's one example a
Republican aide to the Senate Judiciary
Committee named Manuel Miranda stole
thousands of documents belonging to the
DNC back in 2002 Cavanaugh denied having
received any of the stolen documents in
confirmation hearings in both 2004 and
2006 some of the documents that were
released show that Cavanaugh
did indeed receive documents from Manuel
Miranda light that's line number one
okay line number two in 2006 Kavanagh
said that he knew nothing about the
warrantless wiretapping under george w
bush carried out by the NSA emails
provided to the new york times in the
last week show that Cavanaugh was
involved in at minimum the initial
discussions around that NSA warrantless
wiretapping program and he specifically
was asked by Justice Department attorney
John you remember him we've talked about
him before about the Fourth Amendment
implications of this program that is
line number two line number three from
Brett Kavanaugh told under oath back in
2006 during that confirmation hearing he
said he wasn't involved in any legal
questions surrounding the detention of
enemy combatants recently released
records show that there are at least
three recordings of Cavanaugh
participating in such discussions line
number four in 2004 Brett Kavanaugh
claimed not to have worked on the
selection of William prior to the 11th
Circuit Court this is a controversial
nomination because at the time prior
called roe v wade quote the worst
abomination of constitutional law in our
country turns out that Cavanaugh was
involved in selecting prior in
interviewing prior and then working on
getting his nomination through the
Senate
these are super clear Kavanagh said
quote I was not involved in handling his
nomination that's from a transcript and
we then have emails where Cavanaugh is
invited to emergency umbrella meetings
about the nomination and confirmation
process for lives lastly number five in
2006 this one's a little more nebulous
Kavanaugh downplayed his involvement in
the nomination of Charles Pickering he
said he wasn't primarily handling it
once again email suggests he was way
more involved than he admitted so
question number one is Brett Kavanaugh
going to be charged with perjury for
these lies the answer is no perjury in
general is notoriously difficult
acute perjury charges take up a ton of
time and research it's not enough merely
to prove that a witness said something
that was false you actually have to
prove that when they said the falsehood
they knew that it was a falsehood that
goes to their state of mind and what was
in their heads so forget about the legal
consequences of the perjury here but now
this becomes part of the bigger picture
around Cavanaugh which is that a huge
portion of the records about him are
being withheld that he has had now a
string of very concerning answers or
really non answers during the recent
confirmation hearings and he has a
history of playing sort of very fast and
loose with the truth and by the way I
know that this is like this ship has
sailed but he shouldn't even be there
right because Merrick garland should be
on the Supreme Court right now President
Obama's nominee who didn't even get
hearings and then of course it's
important not to forget that we may be
dealing with a president who achieved
the White House through criminal
collusion with a foreign power so
there's like the third layer and then
the second layer and then the primary
layer which are all of these lies that
Bret Cavanaugh has been caught telling
historically all of these are reasons
that Democrats and Republicans should
grow a spine and say if there was ever a
nominee that needed to be blocked it's
this one okay you know I said I was
going to consider whether or not John
Roberts was the right person for the job
but in the end it was really no reason
other than political disagreements to
not put him on the court or Republicans
with you know Sonia Sotomayor or one of
President Obama selections put that
aside and say this is different I've got
a president who may have achieved the
White House illegally we have a
situation where it was wrong it was
wrong to block Merrick garland from
having hearings and the guy that Trump
has nominated we're not getting the
records he's lying under oath he's not
answering questions we have to say no
this time is there any chance that
they're actually going to do that
probably not probably not send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David
and show and it is great to be back with
you today I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka Steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a 7 day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
NK is t.com forward slash PA k ma n